magg merci à vous deux merci d'avoir été
là merci beaucoup on va passer tout de
suite à l'invité du soir et on va
revenir sur cette affaire concernant
Vincent sirouti l'animateur a récemment
été mis en examen pour agression
sexuelle il aurait mordu les fesses de
l'une de ses collaboratrices à plusieurs
reprises si ce dernier déclare qu'il
s'agit uniquement de jeux entre
collègues il semblerait que la plignante
ne soit pas du même avis on fait un
petit récap et juste après on en ser un
peu plus sur cette affaire puisquon aura
myiam Palomba et on a eu un ancien
salarié de Chéry FM ù qui travaillait à
l'époque voilà qui nous a donné un
témoignage exclusif maintenant c'est la
vie de ce salarié cet ancien salarié FM
vous allez voir ce qu'il dit c'est assez
fou regardez
recap bien connu des téléspectateur de
TF1 pour avoir présenté Danse avec les
stars Vincent serouti est aussi un homme
de radio et a notamment animé la
matinale de Chéry FM bienvenue sur Chéry
FM pop love music merci d'être avec nous
et selon le journal Le Parisien
animateor aurait eu des propos et un
comportement déplacé envers une
collaboratrice de la station il y a
quelques années mise en examen pour
agression sexuelle dans cette affaire
Vincent serouti a pu compter sur le
soutien de sa compagne absatousi le père
formidable que tu es à tout mon soutien
s'il y en a une qui te connaît c'est moi
alors l'homme s'est-il exprimé sur le
sujet a-t-il reconnu les faits que lui
reproche-t-on concrètement l'animateur
Vincent serouti mise en examen pour
agression sexuelle que s'est-il
passé que s'est-il passé merci Myriam
PAL d'être avec nous cette histoire est
est folle Vincent serouti bien sûr on
sait très bien qui est Vincent serouti
hein et on aura des audios exclusifs
dans un instant qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé selon la plaignante on va en
parler avec Myriam Palomba il est 20h56
et cette affaire est folle c'est vrai
que quand je vous l'ai lu les gens ont
rigolit ici mais c'est vrai que c'est
c'est pas drôle pour la la plaignante he
la p il aurait mordu les fesses de l'une
de ses collaboratrices à plusieurs
reprises euh et lui a déclaré qu'il
s'agissait que d'un jeu mais on a envie
d'en savoir un peu plus cette affaire
parce que c'est vrai que on comprend pas
il aurait été mis en examen pour
agression sexuelle c'est une histoire de
fou alors myiam euh déjàance routil on
connait Danse avec les stars Danse avec
les stars il a fait c saisons de Danse
avec les stars il a animé les les
matinales l'été sur RTL il a animé il a
été l'animateur star des matinales de
Cherry FM il a participé au grossett
actuellement il est sur la radio MFM
donc voilà un animateur plutôt dans la
catégorie des animurs des animateurs
star de la radio alors euh justement
cétait à l'époque où il travaillait sur
Cherry FM la matinale de Cherry FM
c'était sur la matinale matin chéri donc
de Chéri FM c'est lesffet remonte à 2015
donc en fait c'est une stante artiste de
34 ans qui qui a porté plainte alors sa
plainte a d'abord été classée sans suite
elle s'est pass elle s'est porté partie
civile et du coup le juge d'instruction
a ordonné une une enquête en en aût en
août 2020 et donc les fait remonte à
2000 qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à ce
momentl al alors c'est donc cette jeune
femme est à l'époque elle était âgée
donc de 34 ans elle était standardiste
sur Chéry FM c'est ça oui c'est ça ce
que je viens de dire donc donc en
fait dès le départ elle arrive donc dès
son premier jour elle raconte que elle
arrive donc le matin à la radio vers 5h
du matin elle monte dans dans un bureau
ou qui était mis à disposition donc de
Vincent serouti et de de la coanimatrice
qui était richeva elle arrive et puis là
déjà première blague un peu potache
vincent cheruti lui aurait dit oh là là
tu as un beau cul dans ce jean ça donne
envie d'aller dedans donc premier
premier contact et puis quelques mois
plus tard là se passe un un accident qui
peut paraître complètement
dément il il revient enfin de de alors
juste cette réflexion elle aurait été
fait devant les les équipes de de Cherry
FM c'est ça devant toutes les équipes de
de de de Cherry FM et T tous les
événements qui vont déroulé par la suite
sont également se sont également passés
devant toutes les équipes donc quelques
mois plus tard un accident encore plus
hallucinant arrive il revient de de la
matinale il s'installe dans le bureau où
il y a toutes les équipes et puis il
s'assoit à côté d'elle et pose ses pieds
sur la table où elle travaille là la
standardise de 34 an complètement agacée
décide de prendre sa chaussure et de la
faire de de l'envoyer à travers la pièce
devant tout le monde là-dessus euh
Vincent cherouti l'aurait attrapéelle
prend elle prend la chaussure de Vincent
serouti ça voilà parce qu'elle est agacé
de de d'avoir ses pieds sur sur la table
où elle travaille et là vaanouti se lève
la prend la plaque au sol et lui aurait
mordu les fesses à travers son pantalon
donc oui c'est sûr que quand on décrit
ça comme ça ça peut paraître un peu un
peu bizarre euh donc là-dessus il lui
aurait fait très mal d'ailleurs il y a
un collaborateur qui était qui qui
assistait à la scne qui lui aurait
demandé d'arrêter en lui disant
attention elle a mal arrête arrête tes
bêtises mais c'est ça il paraî qu'elle
aurait hurlé elle aurait hurlé voilà
donc d'ailleurs elle rentre chez elle le
soir elle s'aperçoit qu'elle a un énorme
bleu sur la fesse elle décide de le
prendre en photo mais le lendemain elle
retourne travailler comme d'habitude
alors après ça se repassait bien avec
ils sont repartis voilà après alors
voilà bah après c'était ce que ce que ce
que décrivent en fait tous les
collaborateurs c'est qu'il y a une
ambiance extrêmement potache on raconte
même C certains collaborateurs racontent
même que Vincent cherouti et le
producteur avaient pour habitude à
chaque conférence à chaque début de
conférence de rédaction de mettre la
main aux fesses des salariés pour leur
dire bonjour voilà c'était un peu une
ambiance de de ce style là et en fait
quelques mois plus tard début 2016 alors
qu'ils font une photo sur les escaliers
qui mènent au studio la jeune femme donc
ça s'accroupie de sur la marche qui qui
est placée devant devant Vincent serouti
et là elle sent un énorme pincement au
niveau des fesses et rebelote il
l'aurait remordu donc et là devant tout
le monde he devant Stéphanie Loire qui à
l'époque était la
coanimatrice de de l'émission et donc là
ça commence voilà vraiment à à dégénéré
on sent qu'il y a un conflit entre lui
et et la standardiste et là ça ça part
en cacahuète encore quelques semaines
plus tard quand Vincent cherouti lu se
mettrait à lui hurler dessus devant
toutes les équipes et lui dire
excusez-moi pour les termes mais je je
retranscris exactement ce que la jeune
femme a dit dans sa plainte tu n'es
qu'une tu vas finir dans un
canivau comme ta mère sauf que sa mère
elle est morte 9 mois plus tôt donc
évidemment là la jeune femme elle est
complètement dégoûté elle sait plus si
elle doit retourner ou pas au travail
elle y retourne quand même et puis là le
le le producteur de l'émission lui
envoie un message via facebook pour lui
proposer d'aller boire un verre dans la
brasserie qui se trouve à côté de la
radio rue boilot dans le 16e et là il
lui fait comprendre que bon vu que c'est
très conflictuel entre elle et Vincent
cherouti ça serait peut-être bien
qu'elle qu'elle aille voir les RH et
qu'elle leur propose une rupture
conventionnelle donc là la standardiste
elle est complètement dégoûtée euh elle
est accablée même et elle décide
d'alerter les représentants du personnel
d'énergie 12 et euh et suite à ça
d'énergie pardon et suite à ça elle se
met en arrêt maladie longue durée et une
enquête euh et euh est engagé au sein
même de la radio une enquête interne et
d'ailleurs voilà une enquête qui a qui a
des conclusions assez assez importante
et assez accablante pour Vincent
cherouti alors on va voir hein parce que
alors donc là il y a une enquête
actuellement il est mise en examen
Vincent choutiou alors il y a une mise
en examen depuis le le le 6 février le 6
septembre dernier euh faut savoir que
l'enquête a commencé euh en août de
l'année d'avant puisqu'elle s'est porté
parti civile et du coup elleelle elle a
porté plin combien de temps après ah ben
c'est 2015 2017 doncelle est tout à fait
à l'intérieur du délai éventuel de
prescription qui est de 6 ans pour une
agression sexuelle et la deuxième
plainte avec constitution de parti
civile date de mai 2020 donc il y a pas
de prescription et il est mis en examen
présumé innocent bien entendu mais
l'enquête ira à son terme je voudrais
juste non pas rectifier mais compléter
par rapport au mot ambiance potache ça
c'est c'est un peu la défense vcent de
ses avocats qui plaid la rigolade
permanente aè après dans les morning
tout ça je vous le dis et je l je prends
pas leur défense mais je dis c'est
toujours ça rigole même i ça rigole le
fou avant l'émission après l'émission
voilà donc ambiance potach on peut le
croire absolument c'est juste que dans
la perception de la standardise c'est
pas une ambiance potach c'est pour ça
qu'elle a porté plainte parce queelle
elle plaide pour l'absence de
consentement c'est toujours ça dans une
agression sexuelle elle elle dit qu'il y
avait pas consentement de sa part c'est
juste que je voulais indiquer d'accord
après on dit il s'était réconcilié à un
moment après le voilà qui en fait le jeu
c'est un peu calmé entre eux mais comme
les épisodes il y a eu plusieurs
épisodes qui se sont enchaînés au bout
d'un moment bah c'est le conflit c'est
c'est c'est envénimé et puis la phrase
qu' lui a dit sur sa maman ça ça ça ça a
mis tout par terre et du coup là on
était plus dans le jeu potage on est
presque dans le selon ses propos en tout
cas elle on est dans le harcèlement
sexuel et le harcèlement moral
d'ailleurs c'est c'est c'est ce qui est
l'objet de sa plainte alors un ancien
salar salari de chir FM nous a fait des
audios exclusifs pour TPMP il raconte
lui aussi sa version puce qui
apparemment il y était alors c'est la
version euh je vous dis de de sa version
à lui on aimerait bien avoir la version
également de de Vincent serouti et et
des proches de Vincent serouti
écoutez tout le monde la matinal a vu ce
qui s'était passé et et personne n'a
rien dit personne il y en a une je crois
qui un moment donné a dit arrête arrête
ça ça lui fait mal il a quand même pris
une heure avant l'émission il l'a réé
deux fois une première fois elle l'a
très mal pris elle a commencé à se
plaindre et personne n'a écouté et
quelques mois plus tard une seconde fois
il a d'ailleurs il a d'ailleurs refait
avec une deuxème personne et c'est là
qu'il a offert des fleurs pour pour
s'excuser alors juste il y a plein de
gens qui me disent comment ça se fait
que c'était en 2015 et que ça arrive que
maintenant alors 2015 et 2016 ce sont
les faits les deux faits d'accord elle
dépose plainte en 2017 on a 6 ans pour
déposer plainte pour agressession
sexuelle donc là elle est tout à fait si
je puis dire dans le timing dans le
temps cette plainte est classée sans
suite en 2019 Cyril et donc dans la
foulée comme ça s'est passé dans
l'affaire PPDA elle redépose une plainte
avec constitution de partie civile en
2020 il y a des juges d'instruction qui
enquêteent qui vont auditionner au moins
10 salariés et d'ailleurs ça fait écho
au témoignage que l'on a là parce qu'il
dit il y avait 10 personnes 10 salariés
ont été entendus et donc le 6 septembre
2023 il y a eu une mise en examen pour
agression sexu céit le temps deenquête c
audio vous allez voir de de de salariés
de de chéie FM il explique que la
victime présumée était réellement
traumatisée par cette scène et que les
marques de morsur étaient
impressionnantes écoutez la fille était
en en pleur les photos sont abominables
c'est c'est c'est c'est au-delà d'une
marque c'est comme si je vouis voir un
film d'horreur vraiment je n'arrivais
pas à le croire très peu de personnes en
plus ont voulu l'écouter elle a pas reçu
un coup de téléphone par un mail rien
alors quand ils font après les
féministes à parl de parité homme femm
et cetera et tout moi ça ça me fait
marer alors myiam donc tu voulais
ajouter quelque chose non mais il y a
une jeune femme aussi qui a témoigné en
disant que elle aussi lui avait fait la
même chose il l'avait plaqué au sol
d'ailleurs elle s'est fait extrêmement
mal au au genou c'est l'épisode don
qu'il rappelle là tout à l'heure le le
le monsieur que vous avez eu où où en
fait elle raconte qu'elle s'est
tellement fait mal au genou qu'elle a
été obligé de passer une arm et que du
coup pour s'excuser voilà il lui a
offert des fleurs le lendemain mais bon
c'était un jeu pour lui mais çaelle
était pas visiblement pour les pour les
salariés qui travaillaient avec lui
alors il revient également sur ce qu'a
dit Vincent serouti qui lui parle de de
je potache et comme j'ai dit voilà dans
toutes les émissions dans les mornings
le matin c'est vrai qu' voilà il y a ça
ça ça peut rigoler énormément on va voir
ce que nous dit ce salarié ti FM de
l'époque non mais oui il y a des jeux
comme il le dit très bien c'est routi il
y a des jeux dans une matinale il y a
pas de souci mais c'est pas des jeux
physiques c'est c'est pour ça que quand
jeentends oui mais souvent il y a des
jeux et cetera bah non là ça n'a rien à
voir tu peux faire des blague potage de
manière orale mais pas physique non il y
a pas des cette excuse des matinales et
des jeux c'est impossible
ouais parce que la version de la
plaignante c'est effectivement plaqué au
sol main dans le dos morsure sur les
fesses donc là on est au-delà de ce que
la plignnante et les juges ont considéré
comme un jeu potage ch non et puis là où
il y a quand même problème c'est que le
producteur de l'émission lui aurait
quand même conseillé de prendre la porte
de de partir donc s'il y a pas de
problème s'il y a pas de harcèlement
moral ou sexuel pourquoi le producteur
lui a de demander de de de de faire une
rupture conventionnelle alors justement
il parle même de pression sur la victime
présumée pour pas qu'elle ne parle
écoutez après il a continué à profiter
de son statut son statut avec la
direction il a continué à à presque
presque l' harceler moralement c'était
du harcèlement moral il lui a même
proposé une rupture conventionnelle pour
qu'elle parte ce qui se fait jamais pour
une standardiste euh oui il y a eu
beaucoup de pressions pour qu'elle se
taise il y a eu beaucoup de pressions
pour qu'elle parte il y a eu des
pressions alors oui c'est ce que vous
nous disiez donc il y a eu des pressions
pour qu'elle se teste pour qu'elle parte
euh en fait et je vais vous dire il
alors je le dis c'est bien sûr la vie de
cet ancien s on aimerait bien avoir le
témoignage où de Vincent serouti ou d'un
proche ou de quelqu'un qui prenne même
la défense de Vincent serouti parce
qu'il a fait il il a parlé de Vincent
serouti et il nous a parlé de ses
addiction à Vincent serouti c'est
présumé addiction puisque c'est c'est
lui qui nous dit ça
écoutez alors Vincent serouti il a
toujours eu cette image de gendre idéal
mais il y a quelque chose que que les
gens savent pas c'est qu'il avait dans
ses bureaux des bouteilles d'alcool
Vincent il avait un gros problème
d'alcool ses routi des fois il arrivait
bourrer mais surtout il y avait des
bouteilles dans le bureau et et et et là
c'était c'était open bar et la direction
a toujours protégé les puissants donc
toi on va te prendre la tête pour un
menu golden à 9 € et et lui on lui a
rien dit on ne lui a rien dit ça c'est
c'est alors ça n'engage que la personne
bien entendu qui raconte ça parce qu'il
y a plein de gens aussi qui défendent un
insensibouti je vais vous lire ça dans
un instant alors moi j'ai j'ai une
proche de de Vincent serouti cet
après-midi effectivement qui m'a parlé
de de de ces problèmes là mais qui ont
été réglés depuis un certain nombre de
temps surtout depuis qu'il est avec sa
compagne àsousi qui l'a quand même bien
remis dans dans dans le droit chemin et
c'est vrai que tout ce qui s'est passé à
cette époque là est quelque chose qui
l'affecte énormément il a perdu
énormément de de de poids suite à cette
affaire voilà il est très il est aussi
très accablé parce que à l'époque il
s'est pas rendu compte que ce qu'il
faisait c'était quelque chose de de
grave et qui pouvait qui qui pouvait
enfin qui qui sortait du cadre du jeun
qui dit que ça fait longtemps qu'il ne
boit plus elle a attendu 2 ans avant de
déposer plainte car il s'entendaiit très
bien avec elle qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça ben oui c'est le le tout
toute la problématique cyil est-ce qu'il
y a une relation c'est ce que disait
miram est-ce qu'il y a une relation
hiérarchique ou entre eux de l'animateur
puissant et de la standardiste qui veut
absolument garder son son job animateur
même un animateur pas puissant je il va
pas mordre les les fesses ah mais non
mais ça ça c'est non mais votre question
c'était votre question c'était pourquoi
qu'elle attardé ça bien sûr qu'un
animateur puissant ou pas puissant il
mord pas les les fesses sinon il est mis
en examen pour agression sexuelle mais
la question c'est est-ce qu'il y avait
entre eux un une hiérarchie une
dépendance voilà est-ce que elle a été
contrainte au silence est-ce qu'elle a
été en quelque sorte brimé après
l'agression sexuelle parce que elle
était confrontée à des puissant c'est un
peu ce que l'employé dit hein alors
justement c'est ça selon lui la
direction a mis 2 ans avant de le virer
il naurait pas arrêté de le couvrir
c'est ce que dit c'est la question c'est
ce que voudront déterminer les juges il
y a une mise à pied quand même pendant
ouais écoutez tu vas nous le dire après
bien euh laaffire elle a quand même
débuté en 2015 et et la direction était
au courant dès dès le début dès janvier
2015 et c'est que en 2017 qu'ils sont
intervenus donc ça ça veut dire qu'ils
ont quand même attendu 2 ans euh
pourquoi parce que parce qu'il le
protégeit et s'il a été viré alors c'est
pas que pour ça c'est un ensemble de
choses mais comme ça commença à
sébruiter ils ont préféré vite s'en
débarrasser en 2017 par rapport à ça
alors ça faisait 2 ans qu'ils étaient au
courant donc bien sûr que qu'il y a une
hypocrisie alors euh Vincent sirouti
vous vous avez papier l'enquête elle a
été l'enquête interne a été démarrée dès
la rentrée de 2016 en septembre 2016 et
après il faut le temps de voilà de voir
les gens et que c'est pour ça qu'il a eu
une mise à pied qu'en 2017 en avril 2017
alors Vincent ses routier reconnu les
fait devant la juge d'instruction
cependant il refuse de les qualifier
d'agression sexuelle selon lui il s'agit
de morsure réciproque dans le cadre de
plaisanterie potache sans aucune
connotation sexuelle avec une collègue
qu'il considérait comme amie ce vendredi
il a publié sur son compte insta un
communiqué de presse écrit par ses
avocats il déclare monsieur serouti
regrette que des faits objet d'une
instruction secrète non achevé soi porté
à la connaissance du public il rappelle
qu'il est présumé innocent et conteste
la qualification juridique des faits la
mor sure qui lui est reprochée il y a 8
ans s'inscrivait dans un jeu certes
stupide réciproque prenant place dans
une ambiance potage d'équipe de matinale
radio ce geste n'a jamais eu la moindre
connotation sexuelle avec le recul
monsieur serouti regrette évidemment
être prêté à des jeux idiots mais
réaffirme avec force n'avoir jamais
commis aucune agression sexuelle
absatousi elle elle a réagi pour la
première fois VI a une publication
Instagram sa femme elle a partagé trois
photos d'eux a fait une déclaration
d'amour à son mari puis a déclaré
qu'elle lui apporté tout son soutien que
s'il y en avait bien une qui le
connaissait c'était-elle message très
fort message très fort et je voudrais
revenir juste sur le communiqué des
avocats que vous avez lu Cyril le mot
essentiel c'est ambiance potach récipro
c'est ça dans réci lesocats voilà vous
avez entre guillets une sorte de
consentement implicite c'estàd que tous
les deux s'amusaient tout exactement on
rigolait on a fait ça ambiance potage
tout sera là-dedans pour le moment pour
le moment les juges qui l'ont mis en
examen ne considè pas qu'il y avait un
acaisement de la part des deux voilà
mais il est présumé innocent bien sûr
alors il est mis en examen là donc exam
sur la MA sur la matinale d' radio
j'adore m radio c'est une radio c'est
top il y reste pour le moment il était
là non mais il le soutiennent même he
pour l'instant d'accord alors il a été
mis en examen donc pour agression
sexuelle euh il risque quoi Gill il
risque alors agression sexuelle c'est 5
ans et 75000 € d'amende si a derrière
l'agression sexuelle il y a une certaine
emprise une ascendance quelle qu'elle
soit et par exemple professionnelle ça
devient 7 ans et 100000 € d'amende voilà
très bien je rappelle qu'il est présumé
innocent faut toujours le voilà bien le
rappeler exactement merci à vous deux
merci d'avoir été avec nous tout de
suite c'est magé sur C merci bu